so over the long weekend donald trump
pulled a stunt
where i guess to prove how healthy he is
and how wonderfully everything is going
with his coronavirus case
in advance of restarting rallies and
town halls and maybe debates which he
did already
he staged a so-called medical exam on
fox news
now it really was not actually an exam
it was a conversation with that same fox
news doctor mark siegel
who a couple of months ago did an
interview with trump about his cognitive
state
and said trump was amazing his cognitive
state is just stunning
this medical exam which wasn't a medical
exam is hilarious because if you listen
to donald trump he doesn't answer a
single question
we learn nothing during this entire
interview other than by process of
elimination
that at the time of this interview
donald trump was still positive for
coronavirus
that's all we learned during this fake
medical exam
so let's get into it uh trump is asked
about
symptoms and basically says nothing
other than he didn't feel strong
and insists he had no breathing issues
that you had
last friday like when you went into
walter reed what were the two most
prominent symptoms that you had
i think didn't feel strong didn't feel
really strong i didn't have a problem
with breathing which a lot of people
seem to have
i had none of that but i didn't feel
very strong i didn't feel very vital
i didn't feel like the president of the
u.s should feel
and i knew there was something a little
bit off
and the doctors at walter reed were
incredible we've known
for a week though that trump was given
oxygen at least once
and probably multiple times and there
were numerous reports about trouble
breathing but
again asked what were your symptoms a
seemingly straightforward question
trump doesn't name any but you'll see in
the next question that all of a sudden
symptoms start to crop up next question
is were you
scared and trump lists medications he
got
were you scared were you frightened well
i took the regeneron
and eli lilly makes a similar very
similar medicine but you have regenerate
you have the eli
lilly version of it and it just
within a period of 24 hours i felt very
different i think i could have left the
hospital a lot earlier
but it made a tremendous difference mark
and uh
you know markedly so and and i just
felt very good it it uh you you would
have sort of a sore throat
just to add to what we were saying but
but i felt
really very very good after taking this
for
a period of time it's a transfusion not
a shot reports actually are that trump
was panicking as his symptoms started
and started asking people at the white
house if he was going to die
like his friend who died of coronavirus
but notice that trump then adds a
symptom there i guess he forgot before
he says well you know i did have a sore
throat
when he was asked about symptoms he said
i didn't really have anything other than
i didn't feel super strong
so okay we've added a symptom trump is
then
asked about medications and this is so
funny
i think trump just doesn't understand
anything i think he's just not a
particularly bright guy
he says he's not taking any medications
right now
but mentions that like eight hours ago
he did take medications take a look at
this
and uh right now i'm uh medication free
i'm not taking any medications as of you
know probably eight hours ago or so i'm
medication free
which frankly makes me feel good i don't
like medication
so trump seems confused about his own
medication regimen he says well
as of eight out in the last eight hours
i've taken nothing well
have you finished courses of those
medications
because if you take something daily
there's a point in the day where you
could say listen
it's been 23 hours since i took anything
well but are you
off the medications or have you just not
taken your next dose yet
bizarre way of answering every single
question
trump later asked again about
medications
and now he sounds completely different
he says i
think really i'm not taking anything and
we are pretty much
finished with medications which is not
the same as i am no longer on anything
take a look at this
what are you taking right now as of
today i think really nothing
uh we pretty much finished
and now we'll see how things go but
pretty much nothing uh
we had our uh final doses of just about
everything actually the tr
the original transfusion that's supposed
to last for about four months
so trump is pretty much taking no
medication
and basically had his last doses
just a few hours earlier like does he
even understand his own treatment
i had a conversation with some friends
over the weekend where we were talking
about
we talked specifically about this
interview which we had all seen
and we were kind of arguing about is
trump here
being strategically vague on purpose
when he answers these questions
or does he not really understand what's
going on
and whether he's taking medications or
or like his own
treatment and the consensus was it could
be a little bit of this a little bit of
that
then donald trump is asked about well
what medical tests did you have
did you have a cat scan trump doesn't
seem to know
what he had take a look you would feel
comfortable can you tell me a little bit
about the tests you had in the hospital
did you have a cat scan what did that
show
yeah they tested the lungs they have
incredible equipment at the walter reed
in fact uh they said no you could leave
your jacket on that's the first that's
ever happened leave your shirt on leave
your jacket on i said i'll take it off
anyway if you want
but literally they tested the lungs they
checked for the lungs and they
tested it with different machinery they
have incredible stuff that i've never
even seen before
and uh it tested it tested good
initially i think they had some
congestion in there
but it tested ultimately it tested good
and with each day it got better and i
think that's why they wanted me to stay
frankly but
the cat scans were amazing the equipment
was incredible i've never seen equipment
like this before
the cat scans were amazing imagine that
and of course
tests like no one's ever seen before i
like that he says they checked for the
lungs
they did find the lungs there reportedly
according to the scans they did they did
find trump's lungs and medical experts
are unanimous trump
the lungs were there as far as trump is
concerned
but it all tested good congestion in the
lungs may be
who knows it's not clear whether trump
actually means
what the medical term lung congestion
means or whether trump means
he was stuffed up in his nose which of
course would be another another symptom
he had not
explained recently it's all wacky and
then
the big question of course that many of
us were waiting for
have you been tested and are you
negative the answer is a pretzel
it's a verbal ink blot take a look at
this are you tested i heard you
i heard you said you were going to test
again today have you been retested
i have been retested and i haven't even
found out numbers or anything yet but
i've been retested
and i know i'm at either the bottom of
the scale or free
when is your next test going to be i
don't know probably tomorrow mark they
test
every couple of days i guess but uh it's
really at a level now that's been
uh great great to see it disappear so
i haven't gotten the numbers but i'm at
the bottom of the scale or
free and he's at a great level when it
comes to the virus
are you positive or negative for
coronavirus
obviously if he was negative at the time
he would have said it
if you look at the letter put out by his
doctor just a few hours later you will
noticeably see
that trump tested negative is missing
from the letter the letter says trump
meets criteria
to stop isolation he's no longer a
transmission
risk he's been fever-free for more than
24 hours
there's no longer evidence of actively
replicating virus
trump has decreasing viral loads
no mention of trump tested negative for
covid and you can bet your ass that if
he attested negative they would be
saying it
ultimately we learned or were told
that trump tested negative literally on
route on a plane to a mass rally in
florida
last night which we will talk about a
little later but as you can see
trump cleared by his doctor to return to
public events and campaigning
and indeed he did and we will get to
that later
make sure you're following me on twitter
i'm d pacman
on twitter what do you make of this
bizarre
supposed medical exam which was a doctor
asking trump questions that he didn't
even answer
let me know what you make of it on
twitter we'll be back after this
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called steady md
they're one of our sponsors you take a
quiz you get matched with a licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video